[Music]
I'm scared professor dumbledore everyone
you're scared of something what is this
yes you're next
that's an unusual one what mr. Scamander
fears above everything else is having to
work in an office sir go ahead and use
ridiculous
[Music]
magic rooms
[Music]
only in rare Souls still means scalp in
shadows
[Music]
was the old ways serve us no longer take
it we've heard the rumors of all
television but he would rise to
dominance over the Wizarding World
so you're asking me to help hunt him
down
I can't move against Grindelwald it has
to be you in your shoes I'd probably
refuse to his late
good evening it oh come on
[Music]
you underestimate your talents mr.
Scamander
their arrogance is a key to our victory
muggles are not lesser
not disposable
you're - couldn't you never met a
monster you couldn't love three days
mr. Scamander do you think tumble to
will known for her
[Music]
are you ghost no I'm alive but I'm an
alchemist and therefore immortal oh
you're gonna fly man
Jake 100 you don't look a day over 375
[Music]
you